hey folks it is phenomenal to be here
back on campus it's 1982 was the last
time I was here playing basketball for
Princeton women we did beat you yes look
we forgotten it I mean but for the
t-shirts that we printed we forgot it we
forgot it was a great game I was playing
power forwards so it's phenomenal to be
back a few years later in this role
talking on a conversation that I would
say is an emerging topic not only across
technology companies but quite frankly
in the spirit of leadership and what
leadership is going to look like going
forward so look my role I'm 27 months in
at Microsoft and I made the decision to
leave the East Coast and come out to
Seattle with my husband because of a
mission really a mission statement you
say who actually makes a decision on a
mission statement other than the Jerry
Maguire movie that you may have seen
which didn't turn out so well for Jerry
initially we really moved on a mission
statement and the mission statement was
to empower every person and every
organization on the planet to achieve
more so I came out to Microsoft
initially to run the worldwide public
sector business that's basically the
Microsoft does across education
government and health in 191 countries I
then was asked about six months ago to
take all of the industries all the
commercial industries to include retail
financial services media comms
manufacturing and to take that in a new
way that we go to market and so that's
what I get to do I circumnavigate the
globe about three times a year meeting
with government leaders industry leaders
all about this Microsoft portfolio but
also about issues that are affecting the
globe so the remit is if you do the
quick math on the matrix six industries
that I have primary responsibility for
across 191 countries across the full
portfolio of Microsoft to include our
cloud portfolio like as your intelligent
cloud our dynamics our dynamics 365
cloud capabilities which is our CRM
business apps across Microsoft Office
and Officer
two-five if you will as well as all that
we do in Windows 10 our operating system
and our devices to include minecraft all
the way to Xbox as well as that really
cool surface if any of you have it
I brought mine if we want to talk at so
that's the remit and it's part of that
journey that sort of brought me to this
conversation around what constitutes the
form of leadership that we need going
forward which fundamentally was not what
I was trained when I was sitting in
these seats a few years ago just a few I
noticed a few of you started to look at
me differently I don't appreciate that
I'm quite young I'm quite young this new
form of leadership is what is a mindset
shift and I did not have it immediately
this shift in mindset of what it takes
to lead in a digital arena is really
something that Microsoft spent a lot of
time with it's really trying to index on
what does it look like we use the words
digital all the time you're going to
hear digital transformation and much of
what I talk about we hear the words
leadership all the time but when you put
the two together it's not as natural as
you might think and what is this new
conversation around leadership in the
digital era and that's really where I
wanted to just leave with you and
particularly those of you who are
stepping into this space at the early
part of your career and I want to leave
you with a little bit of a provocative
message as well as a bit of a call to
action that leadership is changing not
only is the pace of Technology changing
and how pervasive it is across work and
home and all things that we want to do
by avocation hobby interest but also
this conversation around leadership is
changing and it's changing because of
the technology and quite frankly
sometimes in spite of the technology so
let me let me highlight where I'm going
with this mindset look the world that
some of you will adopt or inherit as you
walk out of these doors is a different
world than many of us had 35 years ago
30 35 years ago when we came out of
doors
like this when you just look at the
sheer size of the population and what
stress that will put on resilience on
infrastructure when you look at for
example that smartphones will eclipse
landlines what does that mean for the
network and the underpinning of smart
phones and how we talk about privacy for
the data on those phones when you start
to look at the fact how much data will
be created how is it stored how is it
accessed what does it look like when
that much data is being created for
every human on the planet every second
of the day look for many of us in my
generation we thought of the jobs we
would have we actually started to map to
the jobs we would have in high school in
college we started to talk about our
careers but we do have a phenomena that
is here and what do you call it Co bot
which is the collaboration of bot and
human some of the new technology and
term terminology but this idea of living
in a mixed reality world is real and
it's coming and it's here in some places
what does that mean for jobs what does
that mean for displacement of jobs what
does that mean for people in categories
that are right for displacement and how
are we ensuring that technology has the
dividend that we anticipate I love that
last one more conversations with your
bot than this human some of you I see
the eyes getting wider and wider some of
you look pleased about that and that's
concerning so I don't know what your
family situation is but if you would
prefer the black family reunion then the
actual family reunion we can talk about
that as well
but fundamentally this ability to engage
with a bot with this form of Technology
of Technology this mixed reality this is
part of the new world order but let me
just set up for you that digital
leadership is about not just building
cool stuff if we were on campus the word
wouldn't be stuff I'll just say that it
does rot it does have the same starting
letter but we love to build stuff
Microsoft is an innovation I
it's just a harness of innovation we'd
love to build innovative products
solutions platforms but this digital
leadership conversation says there's
something beyond building cool stuff
there's something about that goes beyond
the responsibilities of what we build to
how we build and implement there's
something about digital responsibility
that's part of this equation and there's
also something about inclusion there's
something about who we build it for so
the what I came out of the generation of
the what what can we build what's the
design what's the use case let's build
let's build what's the model but you're
in a generation quite frankly and we
have to as a globe as leaders as
entrepreneurs have to start to define
this more broadly have to define it with
responsible digital leadership being
willing to take on the rule of law of
policy to take on even your own
Department of Justice if you disagree
with their perspective on privacy and
privacy of data the willingness to take
on the less sexy stuff of how do you
handle cross-border data how do you
handle privacy in the EU what does it
look like what does AI really look like
in terms of equity how do you handle
digital equity and then inclusion who's
benefiting from all the stuff this cool
stuff we're building that's the
conversation that we're calling and I'm
starting to quite frankly index on this
conversation of digital leadership and
it's not just about how pervasive the
technology is it's about the reach that
you have to have a day in the life has
to be able to start with a Minister of
Finance in Botswana
move to the head of Rockwell Automation
on a manufacturing plant floor moved to
Cleveland Clinic and Abu Dhabi and talk
about the future of the healthcare
continuum move quickly to JP Morgan
Chase and talk about blockchain
technologies and move very quickly very
quickly into the city next conversation
that's happening all around the world
particularly in Singapore in India and
different parts of the world that's what
a day in the life of digital leadership
looks like and there is not one skill
set there is a multitude of skill sets
that are needed
to operate in this space feel advanced
for a minute Susan you know last year
each year I go to the UN General
Assembly last year if you remember the
UN General Assembly some some of you may
know what happened in 2015 but in 2015
193 leaders came together at the UN and
agreed on 17 sustainable development
goals that would take our our planet to
2030 17 goals 17 goals about clean water
about education about health about
gender equality the last time 193
leaders around our global agreed to
anything I think we should just
celebrate that but we have these 17
sustainable development goals every year
I go back to talk about what should
companies like Microsoft be doing to
drive that conversation so last year I
was in New York President Obama at that
time had asked all the tech leaders for
a call-to-action for the Syrian refugee
crisis how do we address the refugee
crisis and all of us came to the table
very quickly to talk about things that
we might do our technology from
Microsoft with Skype translator how do
you translate if you're a refugee that
falls into a camp you don't speak the
language there we talked about how would
we do digital literacy everybody brought
all of our competitors we were around
the table wonderful time with with
President Obama president by President
Biden George Clooney I did have some
focus there but his wife was right next
to him but she was really really quite
bright and we had a wonderful and deep
dialogue about this but in reality the
conversation that probably shifted my
mindset the most was a conversation with
a hundred and fifty plus women from
refugee camps and these women sat on a
panel and told me what the life in a
refugee camp look like and that was the
call to action they gave me don't teach
me to sew in these camps teach me to
code I want to be part of the digital
transformation in fact don't send me
another program that takes me backwards
I want to go forward that was what got
my attention on how pervasive not only
technology but if you don't have a shift
in mindset you're not even thinking
about the reach that's needed with these
technologies on
who we need to be able to address how
far we need to go so when you think
about pervasive technology you think
about a more connected globe of 7.4
billion people you think about some of
the challenges you're going to face I
put forward to you that the construct
that I'd love you to take away if
there's two words to take away from
these 40 minutes together is digital
leadership and what does that mean
fundamentally that means we're going to
transform it's digital transformation is
occurring every industry around the
world I work with large companies down
to the CEO of Ring MD a 24 year old that
came up with an idea in Singapore to
provide a doctor for every person in a
marginalized area 8 million patients
later this 24-year old CEO has created
something that is moving faster than
almost anything I've seen on this part
of the world so small companies a few
folks in a garage a few folks thinking
of an idea to large companies some of
the largest companies in the world
everyone's transforming almost every
company is becoming a software company
Thyssen crew an elevator company an
elevator company elevator is a service
really these guys are all in front of
creating something new something new and
bringing their market their products to
market as a service with the utility you
want to go into fastest ride on the
elevator
there's elevator as a service Thyssen
group is using IOT or the Internet of
Things the technology and sensors to
find out how to manage elevators in some
of the most efficient ways around the
world so everyone's transforming but
it's not just enough to transform it's
also required to have responsibilities
to think about how not just what but how
we transform how do we stand on privacy
what principles do we stand as a company
and quite frankly as a set of companies
as an industry what do we believe in
what do we stand for as it relates to
transparency or security or compliant
what do we stand for we talk about
artificial intelligence how far are we
willing to go how far we willing to go
in bot technology this is a conversation
that we're having and then finally
inclusion it's
in that uber it's in that uber Venn
diagram that I would argue and I would
put forward to you the digital
leadership is what's needed for everyone
on the planet to think about the
responsibilities of digital leadership
so let me give you a few kind of
examples and definitions here when I
talk about it I'm not saying this is all
Microsoft you've seen some of these
headlines when you when you look at the
charts you know that every company is
trying to work through this conversation
about where are they going to fall on a
digital leadership continuum whether
it's IBM in this conversation about new
collar jobs the 1.8 million deficit they
see in cyber jobs going forward by 2020
that deficit they're trying to create
more cyber security training for new
collar jobs it's interesting this quote
from from the the j.crew CEO speaking to
I did not realize the disruption in
retail that would occur with online
retail how it would compress the cycle
from design design incorporate if you
will design concept to actual purchase
how that's being condensed with
real-time purchase real-time design did
not know the disruption that would occur
when you look at obviously Facebook and
all of the innovation that they are
talking about here what they're trying
to do in invest in India in Access 40%
of India in rural populations that don't
have access not only don't have Wi-Fi
actually don't have access in many ways
to the basic elements of the digital
economy making those kinds of
investments obviously Apple all about
their supply chain and the renewable and
setting criteria for their supply chain
on renewable the ability to drive
renewable energy and obviously Microsoft
I don't know if you're aware that we are
convening a digital Geneva Convention
some of you don't remember maybe what
the Geneva Convention was so before I
put digital in front of it maybe I need
a contact I need to ground us there but
literally we're talking about bringing
countries together what constitutes a
cyber crime
what principles do we agree to as a set
of countries around how we're going to
enforce cybersecurity this is a new
conversation an old model Geneva
Convention old model but in a new
context this is the conversation that
companies are having and this is a
conversation that requires digital
leaders and each of you has got to start
to think about whether you're in
engineering I came to this conversation
through economics through modeling
whatever way you get to this
conversation you've got to think about
principled ways to consider how you want
to go forward in technology because the
technology will allow you to go much
further than our rule of law than our
policies in our regulatory environment
even sometimes beyond the human domain
so with that let me just give a couple
examples we talk about digital
transformation and Microsoft and four
pillars basically four ways every
customer and please feel free to check
me on this go on our website take a look
every customer that we serve we talk
about digital transformation in four
ways we first start talking about how do
you engage your customer let's transform
how you engage if you're a hospital how
you engage in your patient if you're a
university how you engaging your
students if you're a government how you
engaging citizens if you're a
manufacturing or is it how you engaging
your employees your plant workers your
technicians how you're engaging how do
you change the collaborative engagement
with your customers and then with your
employees number two those employees
that work for you how are you changing
that form of engagement three with
optimizing this legacy infrastructure
that's very very old and often very very
expensive to maintain how do you
modernize your operation with obviously
cloud and cloud services and data
centers that are current and new
capabilities and hybrid cloud and
finally probably the most exciting how
do you transform your business model how
do you go from a company that builds X
to providing maybe solutions and
services maybe you even enter a new
market or you create a new revenue
stream because you're changing your
business model a few examples of the
transformation that we see you know it's
interesting when you look
business leaders 80% of them believe
that they will be disrupted by digital
and they're not ready they feel it they
sense it they're not ready certain
industries are moving faster than others
you can imagine which industries might
be lagging which types of industries
would be lagging health very tough with
the regulatory requirements Financial
Services very tough interestingly enough
insurance stepping out in front
manufacturing out in front with mixed
reality and various forms of technology
but some industries are really
struggling but they know they've got a
challenge and then almost I think the
word there is half believe that their
business model is going to change so if
you're just on the b-school side of the
engineering and you you're learning
you're in this engineering program and
you want to ultimately be a business
person you want to own your own business
or work for a large company or a small
company the business models that you're
learning in school you've got to learn
how to think about a business model
don't get yourself wed to any one model
because they're all changing this is
about how do you think about business
models how do you think with this
rationale a few examples these are this
is sort of a day in the life these are
all my customers whether it's lows lows
is using you see what they have there
they have the hololens on that's our
mixed reality device what are we doing
that's for kitchen design that's so that
you can literally use hand signals in a
holograph to manipulate a holograph of
what kind of kitchen you want to design
before you purchase it this is designed
to purchase real time at Lowe's
holograph the signals are incredibly
cool I just pretend like I'm using them
sometimes just to show people all right
my kids think this is amazing this but
when you've got that hololens on it's
not just about augmented reality
it's about mix reality which means you
can see the physical world and the
digital world at the same time it means
you can manipulate the holograph that's
what the future looks like in the future
is in fact now at Lowe's you know let's
talk about students for a minute
we talked about some of the capabilities
we do in education one of the challenges
I live I moved to the state of
Washington 20
seven months ago an Tacoma which is a
city a city in the suburbs from southern
part of the state real challenge on high
school graduation in fact the state
pretty challenged on high school
graduation rates in Tacoma the high
school graduation rate graduation rate
in 2010 was about fifty five percent
just over half graduating so they came
to Microsoft to say hey we want to use
some machine learning some big data and
some analytics some predictive analytics
to see could we predict what what what
are the conditions that create a child
not graduating from high school let's
profile it let's find it let's create
the use case and then let's test it and
let's determine how we can intervene
before that time so they started the
process using machine learning using big
data using analytics on our Azure cloud
platform and over time push graduation
rates from 55% to 82% they are now 2016
last call this 82% that's the shift that
can happen with just analytics just
knowing when and have intervene in the
school process in the educational life
of these students you know a 2015 Nepal
had a huge huge earthquake huge probably
one that told every resource out of the
UN Development Program huge huge
earthquake that hit interestingly enough
the UN reached to Microsoft and said hey
we need help and we started building
apps immediately with partners on the
ground you know what the apps allowed
people to do these don't sound
interesting probably in this context but
I want you to know that two days after
the quake we had victims of the quake
using applications on debris management
categorizing the debris they were paid
through this app they were given ways to
sustain themselves and to rebuild their
community two days after the quake we
had apps on the ground moved this is the
role of Technology in real life my world
is falling apart 6,000 people dead all
of the massive massive loss of life and
infrastructure 48 hours people
went from being victims to working on
the solution in the recovery and then
one of my favorites Ecolab I don't know
if you all heard of Ecolab Ecolab's
yet we've got some nods but what a great
company really Ecolab's business model
was around tools and and and products
that they built to manage water really
they're a water management company but
they came to Microsoft and said hey we
want to be more disruptive in our market
we think that we can disrupt because
there's a lot of data that we can
collect with sensors in all of the water
and we know there's a water crisis a
water crisis in the world that's growing
not just for drinking water but water
for underpinning manufacturing and other
operations so we talked about the grid
the the electric grid the energy grid
what about the water grid and so they
started coming to us and started to use
our machine learning algorithms and they
created this risk this risk equation in
this risk tool for water and now they're
creating water as a service under
helping countries and companies
understand their water crisis and
starting to intervene earlier how
they're going to manage it as well as
bring down the use of water which
they've been able to do San Antonio is
one of the best examples where they
brought down the use of water potable
water so significantly by using just
data how to intervene when to intervene
that's the kind of work that I have the
opportunity to do Microsoft has the
opportunity to and and quite frankly you
have the opportunity to do with these
types of customers but that's
transformation it's exciting and this is
our day to day and boy we love it but
boy we also spend a lot of time on our
principles this was really important to
join a principled company or to be a
principled company you've got to have
your principles in place before the
disaster hits by the way you've got to
set principles before the challenge
comes if you're starting to look for
principles after a challenge you're a
little bit late you have to set your
principles of what kind of company you
want to be and then you've got to
implement them when the challenge comes
so we've got principles around privacy
and security is and transparency showing
our government customers
data in government transparency Center
cybersecurity centers around the world I
just launched to last year in Singapore
and in Brasilia this is about who we
stand for and what we stand for
protecting human rights ensuring
sustainability and ethics in AI so what
is that why is that important
it's important because what may not be
in the news all the time is a few
companies get the call every time
there's a cyber attack we get the call
wherever the attack is whether it be
France Belgium the UK the US we get the
call and we start pulling the
information that we have from a digital
crime unit that we run that just tracks
lot net activity around the world we
don't do this for a charge we do this
free of charge we do this and we feed
this information to Interpol we feed it
to the US we feed it we feed information
on what's occurring in the cyber in the
cyber space and this is the kind of
challenge that we have to try to address
but not just cyber beyond cyber this AI
conversation has been so amazing we've
been leading at AI but as you lean into
AI you better have a point of view on
privacy you better have a point of view
on the trade-offs you better have a
point of view on things like algorithmic
bias anybody heard of algorithmic bias
what happens when your facial
recognition doesn't recognize faces of
people who are brown or have different
facial features people that look like me
what happens because we say coding is
neutral well coding is not done by
neutral agents people code and our
people neutral not always it doesn't
even mean malicious it just simply means
not aware and so some of the new work
that's come on algorithmic bias I love
the work from joy and I never get her
name correct Walla bleah me I think just
recently did some work on the coded gaze
right some of you are nodding work that
she's found on the bias racial bias and
algorithmic coding gdpr
a new privacy standard for Europe is
coming a privacy standard that says that
you that every European has the right to
understand how their data is used in an
algorithm they have the right to be
forgotten they have the right to audit
these are changing the way we start to
build applications and how we deal with
privacy and data because if you're going
to step into AI and you're going to lead
in AI you better know what the end looks
like and the end looks like a
conversation about how far are we going
to go and what are we going to protect
along the way that's why we're involved
in some of these conversations I just
came from Hannover Messe Hannover Messe
is one of the largest manufacturing
events in the world and I was there with
a number of Microsoft partners and this
was a conversation was all over Hannover
in Germany all over humans and machines
we probably had nine or ten partners in
production using artificial intelligence
and bot technology using hololens and
mix reality in the way that engineers
and service technicians were actually
doing work and so the conversation was
on human and machine and it was on
digital twin if you haven't done the
research on digital twins I would invite
you take a look Digital twin is the
holographic twin of everything that's
created in the physical world that we
create in the digital world so that we
can manipulate and train and work in the
digital world before we have all of the
consecrates consequences and
implications of the physical world
there's some wonderful applications
wonderful think about medical training
training a surgeon where you can take a
holograph and train and pull out the
circulatory system and the nervous
system and literally manipulate a
holograph to Train think about
population health remote telehealth
where we can take things to remote areas
think about a jet engine like
rolls-royce that would fill up this
entire room we couldn't move it here but
I could bring a holograph here and we
could operate that jet engine right here
and I could teach you how to learn how
to train it how to maintain it right
here in this room with the Hollywood
that's the future and
current but it also concerns a lot of
people where the jobs going who's being
affected by this inclusion this is
really about and probably I'm going to
if I'm the last speaker of this series
and clearly we have saved the best for
last I want to thank you for that and
that's how I'm receiving your feedback I
am but probably let me save the best for
last here all of this matters when a
digital transformation or a digital
economy is accessible and democratized
for everyone and so there is a very real
chance that if we're not purposeful
about this conversation that all the
investments in digital transformation
won't have the outcome that we're
looking for so we spend a lot of time on
programs yes Microsoft and our
competitors do this this is not this is
not an infomercial for Microsoft this is
a conversation that I want to have with
you about how you design and build in
the new world because if you're not
careful you might end up with something
you don't anticipate if you flip to the
next slide here's the study that was
done by by the World Economic Forum and
the study basically shows that by 2020
for every one digital job that is
created for a man for traditional jobs
will be displaced now what that may be
concerning to you that's a one to four
ratio fair to get kind of sit up in your
seat but I'd like you to sit up a little
further in your seat because for every
one job created for a woman 20 jobs
would be displaced now why is that now
you get to put on the economics hat for
a minute women around the world are
disproportionately in labor categories
that are right for digital
transformation so when you're
disproportionately in a labor category
that will be transformed the impact of
that transformation is going to be more
severe so what does that say to a
company like Microsoft if we're not
intentional about programs for
entrepreneurial activity digital
literacy and getting more women through
stem which by the way is going in the
wrong direction right now in this
country doing better outside of this
country if we
not intentional about that as a company
we'll have a digitally transformed
workforce we're going to have a few
people that are amazingly digitally
literate highly highly agile but the gap
and the divide is going to be worse than
it is today so this is why companies
have to be thoughtful and intentional
and purposeful because the data says
it's left to our own devices we'll just
keep creating and we'll still build
really cool stuff stuff is a code word
we'll build cool stuff but we will
divide the world even more than it is
today
so this is about a mindset you all might
know that lady Carol Dweck I think she's
here her husband here you know she's
been helping us at mine at Microsoft
about our mindset she's done work on a
growth mindset so we're all learning how
to be really excited about learning more
versus knowing more those are simple
words but they're actually pretty
profound at a company like Microsoft
learning more versus knowing more not
what you know is how you learn I came up
from a generation that it was what you
knew we differentiated by what we knew
now it's not about that what you know as
interesting as it is it's more about can
you find what you need to know and do
you know your own mindset to know how
you learn so this is mindset it's not
about a few pointers it's about a
fundamental shift a fundamental shift in
mindset it's about three domains of
knowledge what you know what you don't
know and I would argue where we all need
to be what you don't know that you don't
know that's where we're living we're not
sure as we build things where we're
going with some of this that's why you
have to have principles and values
upfront and you got to test and test and
test your own bias test and test I want
to kind of wrap with how I got here
because it sounds it sounds pretty heady
and professorial to put all this on
slides and say hey here's where we are
here's here we're going forward but
probably a hundred years ago I was
sitting in a chair like you and when I
left Princeton I decided to go to Peace
Corps
and I decided to go I thought because of
my foreign language cable because I
spoke French I thought I'd just choose
my country that's not quite how the
Peace Corps works I thought I'd choose
my village not quite how the Peace Corps
works so when I got to Gabon in Central
Africa he said hey the people with the
highest FSI score or foreign language
score we're going to send you the
farthest away because you'll be fine so
as I said goodbye to all my colleagues
and friends I kept going and I kept
saying are we there yet no not so much
so I flew to France Ville and I took a
bridge taxi up the coast almost on the
plateau of the Congo finally I arrived I
arrived at in warning my village as an
African American I was wearing African
garb so that I could greet I was
thinking I was going to have us a real
reunion experience I was ready my friend
my family I am home I am here I'm so
excited and I heard the children singing
walk bongani and I thought oh they're
welcoming back our sister our black
sister as a rise egg it took about an
hour for me to realize of autonomy met
white person I was confused
I kept showing them that I am here I am
back
why did it mean white person why did
they call me well Tonga me because I
came in a Toyota Land Cruiser and it
wasn't about color was about
socio-economic capability if you come in
a truck you're white if you don't if you
walk in without shoes you're black
imagine my first cross cultural moment
how well I did in this village but I
stayed and I persevered and I taught six
classes and I played soccer the first
woman to play soccer in that village and
I'm the first person to start a strike
and I did a teacher strike because I
found that some of my female students
were being assaulted by the Jean d'Armes
so I brought all kinds of things to the
village one of the ideas that I had was
we were going to catch rainwater because
the rainy season in Gabon is like no
other rainy season I've heard and you
know what every day we walk to water and
I had so many villages that I would
visit and we always walked about three
kilometres to get water and women
carried heavy heavy heavy potable water
and I thought I can fix this
I can fix this take the rain water I'll
go get some money
the US Embassy which they gave me
another mistake they gave me money and
they said hey if you do a woman and
development project you're ready to go I
started a women and development project
got all the women together in the
village that I mentioned the Gabon is a
polygamous country up to four wives
legally so I took all the middle wives
that seemed a little bit irritated a
just seemed pissed most of the time the
second and third wife so I said let me
get all the second and survived the
first wives look pretty happy the fourth
wives didn't seem to care they're pretty
young and cute but the second and third
wives I needed to work with so I got all
the wives together and I started this
water project we're going to capture
rainwater we're going to capture it in a
French video and I'm going to put a
filter on it we're going to save the
kids that died in my village from
dysentery and all forms of diarrhea
we're going to do this and I started
this project and I knew I would I mean I
was 23 years old I had a Princeton
education it was not quite Stanford but
I was there I was there I'm making a
difference I'm writing notes how I'm
like this is it in the course of about
six months I also introduced divorce to
my village I introduced a level of chaos
that is unimaginable at 23 I had created
a village that didn't get together in
the middle of the village anymore and
have festivals and have big bonfires no
everybody stayed at their home I had
created in New York City
I was in the Bronx and so here I am at
23 none of the elders spoke to me the
women took the tools and traded them in
for money that was more than their
husbands could earn in a year I mean I
had totally disrupted here's here's the
lesson here I had to go back and
apologize to every elder I had to go
back and learn that the walk to water
that I was fixing is not about are your
legs strong enough to go get water that
was a time of the day where Gabonese
women would take the next generation and
wrap them on their back or walk with
them in the hand and it was woman time
it was girl time and I was trying to
kill that so I could get the efficiency
of water I did not realize what that
walk meant so if you go to Gabon to my
village in Guam I go to France Ville
take the bush taxi two hours up and you
get to in brownie
are the water stations still there yes
they are and older women use them and
when you have a new baby they use them
but you know what they still walk for
water they still walk for water because
the walk was not about the walk the walk
was about community that's the lesson
that I remind myself that we all bring a
bias and technology will allow you to do
so many things but don't ever forget
that when you're using the technology
it's not just the end it's a means to an
end the end of still people and culture
and fabric and principles and values and
we've got to use the technology to
protect values those are timeless those
are what you think about in your last
moments on this earth not how cool your
device was that was my lesson I just
want to leave it with you that digital
leadership is what we're looking at as
the new form of leadership going forward
it is more than the transformation with
cool devices and cool technology it is
responsibly deploying that technology
being aware of how it's being consumed
and it's also about being inclusive to
ensure that the digital dividend is in
fact accessible to all thank you very
much for that time
I think I believe we have some time for
Q&A I think we have some Q&A in the room
and maybe a few folks yes I do we have
mics or do we need mics we don't need
backs even better okay yes sir
start with you thank you so much for
going okay so you talked about having
principles for making in business and
all these sorts of Ages and so there's a
few things that happen online like
blockchain and privacy and when you're
dealing in fear of there's obviously lot
of division in the subject and when you
deal with JP Morgan is something that's
a lot of division and concern your
blockchain encrypted goods so how do you
avoid picking favors or you walk around
just sort of having a one-size-fits-all
principle when you're dealing with these
sorts of issues it's a great question so
the question is around how do you then
balance the various constituencies
whether it's a JPMorgan Chase and
blockchain down to a EU and and privacy
and model clauses and where we're going
you know there's probably I would say I
would answer it two ways first the
principles around that that Microsoft
has put in place have really been there
for a number of years and principles
around he who owns the data the privacy
of our end-users that they own their
data they are the only ones that can
distinguish where that data should
should locate our ability to be able to
locate that data for them make sure that
we can access access and show them where
their data is as well as their ability
to define how that data is used that's
one of the core principles another would
be transparency these are overarching
principles how transparent are we going
to be with our source code the fact that
we open up our source code every
government in the world and show them
exactly what we're doing if we're
working in that country that they have
that full transparency those are privacy
and transparency principles that I would
say eclipse almost any organization but
you do bring up a conversation that we
we have even more which is global and
local Maxima there's a global Maxima
things that happen where if you will the
return is is much larger on a global
Maximus where are you going to put your
resources for a global Maxima where
you're going to put your investments of
data centers people asking us or where
were you put in your data centers where
do we put our infrastructure you can
look and do big math I would call it and
say at the macro there are a few regions
that you have to be in it's a global
maximum there are still a local maximum
how do you build a developer community
in an emerging market
you can't sell to an emerging market
unless you build an emerging market
first so these are the sort of
trade-offs that we are making and I will
tell you that it's checked the track
record that we've had has been really
strong on certifications if you know the
Microsoft Microsoft history
certifications and compliance privacy
standards and principles transparency is
huge for us
but I will tell you on AI we're really
starting to define what we call the sort
of cobalt living this is collaboration
between bots and human what is that
going to look like going forward and how
do we ensure that that's complimentary
it is not a replacement approach but a
complimentary approach that's where
we're spending our time on new kinds of
use cases so the global and local max
where the new terms that most companies
are trying to figure out what can we do
at a global level but what then still
needs to be done at local and where do
we make trade-offs but I will say to you
privacy transparency security and
compliance all of you should push every
company that's the size of Microsoft to
actually codify for you what their stand
is and that's what we're going to start
to do in the digital Geneva Convention
so great question great point yes ma'am
question four inches tall one is that
computers in general using a strong
amount of energy so you know when we
talk about any people dishes or how very
digital well energy how much and very
polyphonic on students that's one
question
secondly and related to that is the
other thing where when could you tell me
when we have this you know all the users
they don't didn't no longer work or
smartphone in around what against jump
take it shift to countries like India
where people are using you know so
everything and they engage those
actually moment of you know health
problem it doesn't eat baby from inborn
you know sort of luck with severe
absolutely so there is also that
downside and so what is with this
additional responsibility what does that
energy one and Easter energy the other
is the poor underdeveloped country in
just India be any other countries you
know we're there for Islam and you see
babies as usual dead or even adults with
the universe problems health problems
cancer and so on because they're doing
all the work in wonders here no it's a
great point so one of the things that
we're doing on the energy side is and
technology can even help us identify
what the sustainable algorithms are so
we're using machine learning to
understand where the data centers that
are driving the most energy usage where
they are around the world that's just
for Microsoft data center any data
centers around the world we do this with
our our customers we use learning and
data to understand where we get the
highest efficiency so that we can load
balanced across for the highest
efficiency and the lowest impact on the
environment and so remember technology
has a sort of two-edged to headed sort
of coin the very technology that we're
using the power behind that for for a
data center can can hurt the climate can
hurt that can hurt the environment at
the same time that same technology can
be used to tell us where to focus our
capabilities so almost all that you
should ask each time and whether it's my
company or any other company is what are
we doing in the balance what are you
doing
what have you learned on where in the
world and should put data centers and
what we can drive and then are you
holding yourself accountable for the
usage in the power that's coming out
what's your green plan if you will for
your data centers and for all technology
usage we are also a supply chain company
ourselves we build things we have about
thirteen plants around the world we use
probably the most sophisticated data
algorithms to know which plants are
emitting the least if you will impact on
the environment and is Drive and then
load balance there now to your point
about emerging markets
one of the challenges and it's great
that you brought that up because one of
the pieces of the digital Geneva
Convention that we're bringing to the
table is this conversation about
emerging markets and if you will almost
this supply chain that has landed in
emerging markets of old technology
whether the old hardware old
infrastructure and it's all coming to
emerging mark what's the implication on
health on population health and mostly
in rural India quite frankly where it's
moving even further out from the cities
into the rural areas that's where we
need all of not only the technology
companies to come together but countries
to come together on what's our if you
will Digital Geneva Convention that's
actually one of the pillars of the
Geneva Convention that we're starting to
bring together is how are we going to
handle the waste if you will of
technology of hardware and where does it
go and what are the responsibilities if
you are dropping that type of hardware
what's your responsibility and liability
as a company and as a country so that's
what we're looking to start to talk
about this is where we need to have a
forum that's much broader than just
Microsoft to have the conversation
that's a great point great point the
collage economy yep as you move more and
we're the robotics and economies acting
clearly that's a brilliant cell phone
users many customers accompanied by
potholes and counseling that maybe you
might not but as we if you fast-forward
that Vista digitization in under call it
a generation not a few years a
generation forward seems like their
tradition and so the customers are Apple
the company Nvidia Microsoft actually
have declines pertain what what what
tell you that's a great so the question
was around it looks like just too many
with we if we continue this sort of
cellphone proliferation and the number
of the population on the planet our is
our customer base that going to decline
over time in the IT space as a result
more fully prolific physically found you
know to be honest when we look forward I
there was a recent Harvard study about
even in manufacturing as we've been
talking about are the plant jobs going
away where where will technicians go
with with
robot and cobalt capability and it talks
about two million new types of jobs by
2020 so what we find is that the type of
job is changing not that there won't be
a job aid but that the type of job and
the interaction with the technology is a
skillset that we're going to need so
we're not as concerned in the IT fear
about not having an opportunity looking
forward we do think that the engagement
and the orchestration is going to change
how people engage with technology in
fact if you look at Microsoft all up
when we started about 42 years ago and
we were in the picking of sort of the PC
market we sort of defined our market
fairly narrowly we then went to the data
center market we defined it fairly
narrowly now when we look at the market
we look at the total addressable market
and it's not just the IT spend it's the
entire company or organization spend
because everything technology has
pervaded everything so from a business
perspective our total addressable market
is actually going up it's going up
because we've defined it over the last
few years
only in IT departments and data centers
that's not when I talked about the
Thyssen group example that's not the IT
department that's the fundamental cogs
or the cost of goods sold for the
business is changing they're now in a
completely different business model
that's the opportunity for not just
Microsoft but companies like Microsoft
we actually see that opportunity going
up so when you think of digital
transformation sort of at its next peak
if you will a few things we think will
happen
we all have we're all watching the
cities right number one issue by 2050
70% of the population being in urban
areas that that migration is one we are
all over right now in terms of what's
the new city
what's the digital city what's that
going to look like what opportunities
are there so there's a big focus on
urban we're also doing a lot more in the
US now on rural areas how do we
transform old competencies to new in
Pennsylvania we're working with coal
miners teaching them to code as an
example how do you teach coding to a
different skill set a different role
transforming into the new so there's a
literacy piece on digital there's a
transformation of the industries itself
and then there's this larger market that
we're looking at as companies are
starting to become all sort of software
companies in their own right so we're
not actually that concern about the
future even quite frankly things going
our customer base going down we just
have a different set of customers and we
our customers now who I'm talking I'm
talking to chief marketing officers I'm
talking to business decision-makers I'm
no longer talking to the CIO I mean I
have those conversations but those
aren't the conversations that Microsoft
is engaging in as much as we used to
we're really now going to the core
mission critical parts of companies and
organizations and I think we see a
larger market not a smaller market as a
result yes all the way in the back there
well coming up so you've had your hand
up right here and then here oh I got
some kind of related to that and what I
point is is there is a little bit of
difference between state literacy and
education and you could learn how to
learn how to speak but a different thing
to learn to know before or to learn how
to understand the law of treasom it ends
the same way and vigil to vigil world
where you can have digitally literate
people but not miss out vigilant
educated people so you can learn how to
use a smart phone but not that's how we
learn how to code it or learn how to use
social media but not necessarily to
learn how to use social media marketing
to very different things kind of my
questions or in my experience like I
grew up in a Philippines as a child and
what I've experienced there with that
there's a really high level of digital
literacy among those peanut bock
relation but a very very low digital
education or even interest for
additional education so there's no push
for people to go in or so major pushing
means for people to learn how to code
I've learned how to educate in the
digital digital type so what are ways
that you could foster that need for
digital education in a market that's
bieber's uninterested or even unaware of
the importance of digital education it's
a great question about the difference
between digital literacy digital
education how immersive digital
education needs to be versus just the
knowledge of devices and various pieces
and what's Microsoft or other companies
doing in that space first let's I'm
ention digital literacy as one asked
what Microsoft and other companies are
focused on but let me come back and go
back to my core of the six industries I
mentioned one of them is education if
you look at the two largest acquisitions
that Microsoft has done minecraft
LinkedIn you might start to connect
those in your head at some point that we
are all in on education so it's not just
digital education this is about changing
the pedagogy the way education occurs
what we call success so we actually when
we go to digital responsibility one of
the things we spend time on are the P's
of standards for education leaning in on
what are the new definitions of what
competency needs to be around the world
moving from language arts and math to
computational learning critical thinking
analytical design driving a new way of
teaching around the world we've created
a new data science curriculum one of the
first of its kind because higher ed what
is the number one job skill that I'm
looking for to hire when I come to
schools like this I need some more data
scientists how do I create more data
scientists as it come out of a cop side
program to come out of an engineering
program going to come out of an
economics program the stats program I
need more data scientists so if you
think about it k12 the investments that
we're making are all around the teacher
first the student we've thrown in this
country we throw in devices at schools
for a decade and it has not changed the
educational outcomes significantly so
here's what we do know we know that it's
not just about cool devices in schools
this is about educators that know how to
work in mix reality I say this as a
former teacher what we can do now is use
real-time data in a classroom to engage
with students around the world and
including the Philippines because we
have a team there around the world on
how to train educators to educate with
real-time data teaching code we've got
1st 2nd 3rd graders coding at very very
young ages because the educator is
comfortable the educator understands we
also have a school leader program guess
what happens once you get educators you
got to get school leaders if you have
school administrators that are willing
to make the investments in digital
education so we have something called
Microsoft innovative educators
certification that we certified teachers
around the world on how to teach in this
new world order and our goal is to get
to every teacher certification program
around the world so that teachers come
out of school ready to teach with this
we don't want it to be digital education
this is education for a digital world so
this we want this to be pervasive and
embedded in education and so I literally
just left one of these conferences that
we are driving this with everyone who's
building capability make sure a lot of
these schools don't have a CIO they
don't have teachers that are paid in a
way that they're going to go get trained
on all forms of technology we've got to
make this easy accessible available and
really straightforward and so so on that
point education is probably our single
largest industry and effort in Microsoft
digital literacy is one element but
let's not forget the foundational piece
which is we got to change the way
education occurs in this country and
around the world
great question ma'am I'm sorry you had
your hand up forever
I apologize and younger children rate
analysis well it's brilliant infant
their digital needed so this Microsoft
or visible leaders may be ultimately
really at that fundamental we could get
rating out as basically yeah that's your
Instagram yeah so family so the question
is how far even early early at even
pre-k I would argue the socialization
how children feel that they're digital
natives that they convey if I look at my
granddaughter's try to move the
refrigerator door because they think
it's supposed to move like they're
starting they're doing this why are you
cleaning what are you doing they're
waiting for things to move the hard book
is supposed to move and do something to
talk to them so what we've done if you
look at minecraft just minecraft how
pervasive minecraft is for that audience
all the way pre-k through third grade
all over minecraft it is one and it's
not just the Minecraft games it's a way
of thinking it's the way that they
structure their thoughts even as an
early early pre-k and so we see that we
see the ability to code with kids even
storytelling the gift of storytelling
there's there's a sequence and story
telling that leads so beautifully into
the ability to program and we start very
early with storytelling storytelling and
component size if you will messages
within your story and so we tend to
focus on right at about four or five
pre-k all the way through higher ed
that's pretty much our market but I
would suggest to you that all that we're
doing on the consumer side with
Minecraft all that we're doing sort of
for families to understand and trying to
quite frankly broaden that so minecraft
has a menu that goes beyond we know that
there are boys that like certain things
girls families that want to engage
together so I think you're onto
something in terms of probably even
earlier in the in the life spectrum we
probably need to go early but our focus
is really pre-k four or five all the way
through higher ed and you're absolutely
right we find that minecraft and then
let's think LinkedIn
what an interesting acquisition the data
on LinkedIn unbelievable so we're
thinking about well how do we career
paths how do we tell every country in
the world what their labor market looks
like how do we take a LinkedIn
capability and effect this jobs concern
this sort of reef skilling what we call
middle skills where you start rescaling
people who are 25 to 65 remember when we
talk education we tend traditionally we
talk K through 12 and higher ed but the
single largest group of folks graduating
right now even in the u.s. are over 25
and that 25 to 65 is called Reese
killing Reese killing people for one
skill set into the digital economy and
that's where we think capabilities like
LinkedIn are going to really help us
coming forward on how to do that how to
connect people to the right opportunity
I have no idea where I am on time I'm
looking oh okay how are we doing I sell
a few hands but you you tell me what to
do alright not one more okay thank you
that's audio thank you very much
[Applause]
you